the hole in the ground is a horror movie
that has a lot to unpack from it the
entire film is full of red herrings
hallucinations and a third act that
leads to more questions than answers so
what exactly can we take from the film
and all the events portrayed a net what
took place well throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the ending of the
movie as well as what I took from it
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything in
regards to the film and I highly suggest
that you turn off now with that out the
way and definition and welcome to the
channel where I explain it so you don't
have to the hole in the ground centers
around Sarah O'Neil and his son Chris
whilst never confirmed we can surmise
that Sarah is escaping an abusive
relationship with Chris's father and
thus the two have moved to a dilapidated
house in the Irish countryside that
Sarah is attempting to renovate at the
beginning of the film when she's out
driving with Chris Sarah nearly hits a
woman who wanders out into the middle of
the road while Sarah initially goes to
check if everything is okay she sees
that the woman is unresponsive to her
and just stand still in the path of
muttering to herself early on this woman
quickly becomes one of the most
intriguing characters of the film and
Sarah's journey somewhat mirrors hers we
learned that she's called Noreen Brady
and that years prior his son James was
killed in a car accident Noreen Brady is
infamous in the area as before James's
death she loudly protested that the boy
was not really her son and that he was
an imposter whilst his death was
seemingly accidental many people in the
village believe that she was responsible
and since the death she has become
extremely disconnected from the world in
the forest that resides next to their
home Sarah and Chris stumble across a
gigantic crater that takes up a massive
part of the area one night Sarah
discovers Chris out of his bed and she
rushes off into the woods to the hole
searching for him believing that he has
been abducted however upon returning
home she discovers that Chris is still
in the house and this leads Sarah to
begin to second-guess her own
perspective on things we also learn
after an examination from a
dr. sarah has a large scar on her head
that could imply that she has had some
form of head trauma that may lead to
hallucinations Sarah slowly begins to
suspect that something is not quite
right with Chris and these suspicions
are given further weight when the to
once again discover Mrs Brady when they
are out driving in the woods Noreen
bangs her head against the car window
and screams he's not your son which
startles the pair until they flee the
next day Sarah goes to talk with Noreen
about her claims however she finds her
corpse with her head buried in the
ground from here the hallucinations come
thick and fast for Sarah and she even
confesses to a work colleague that she
finds Chris unrecognizable after
speaking with Noreen's husband at her
wake she becomes convinced that Chris is
an impostor and when out jogging in the
woods discovers one of his toys around
the hole even though she gave him strict
instructions not to leave the house by
himself
Sarah stares at the hole and it begins
to warp and transform for her which to
me is the director expressing that when
you gaze into the abyss the abyss gazes
back there's an alternative theory on
this that'll cover at the end of the
video but for now let's just stick to a
surface level interpretation when
confronting Chris he displays
overwhelming strength and one night
Sarah witnesses is running around on all
fours chasing a spider before eating it
Chris's body seems to warp and Bend in
strange ways and out of fear Sarah gets
him examined by a doctor whilst the
doctor finds nothing out of the ordinary
Clare still suspects something is wrong
and sets up a camera in his room to
record him when watching the tape back
she believes it shows proof that he is
not her son and she shows it to Noreen's
husband who smashes the camera out of
anger
due to the grief over his son and wife
resurfacing Clare puts sedatives in
Chris's food and challenges him to play
their favorite game staying that they
haven't done it in a while Chris blankly
stares at her as she counts down which
confirms to her that he is indeed an
impostor Chris attempts once more to
convince her that he's real however
after this fails he begins to fling her
about the room and attacks her with
phenomenal strength he eventually drags
her into the forest and buries her head
but due to the sedatives from earlier
passes out which gives her time to break
free and take his body back to the house
in a mirror Clare witnesses that he is
indeed creature
which is referred to in the credits as
it back at the house it awakens but
Claire manages to hit its head which
causes it to scream and pain and whether
on the ground from here she journeys to
the hole in the woods and after climbing
in discovers that there or a race of
creatures living there that can mimic
humans perfectly similar to their name
counterpart in the other horror films
these eight creatures seem to
predominantly go after children and live
under the ground there is evidence that
they've been doing this for decades upon
decades due to the amount of corpses in
the caves and we can guarantee that
James Brady was indeed a victim of them
Claire manages to rescue Chris and
revive him before returning to the house
to set it on fire
normality returns to their lives however
with Claire we get the feeling that she
still suspects that Chris may not be who
he says he is she over analyzes photos
that she secretly takes of him and hangs
up a large amount of mirrors in their
home signifying that the doubt and
paranoia may start to creep over her
once more okay so the main question that
many will have is what are the monsters
in the hole in the ground well judging
by the size of the crater and massive
air it appears to be from a meteorite
thus it's a pretty clear assumption that
the monsters are aliens when running to
the pit we even see aircraft flying over
the area and it seems strange that the
director would leave this in instead of
waiting for it to pass by which confirms
to me that they wanted to show that the
area has a lot of UFOs in it it appears
to ominously point towards the hole and
seems almost like it's being drawn into
it which to me is a pretty clear
signifier similar to the aliens from the
thing and even here which the creatures
are named references to they are able to
shape-shift and assimilate with humanity
however their goals don't seem to be to
conquer the world and therefore we can
imagine that they are parasitic in
nature which is why they are forced to
live underground and feed off children
who wander into their paths
another question that viewers may have
is is Chris an alien at the end well
just because Sarah managed to rescue
Chris doesn't mean that she took the
real one out remember
these creatures are incredibly accurate
duplicates and the fact that there was
another skeleton could confirm that all
she did was take out
a copy was the corpse she stumbled over
Chris's and did the creature just send
out another movie well either way Sarah
seems to have the apartment set up to be
aware of this and the fact that she's
moved into a more open area means that
she's putting more of the population at
risk if it is indeed it so she probably
doesn't think that it is personally I
don't believe that he's a monster and I
think that the film is pretty much what
actually happens unless of course my
other theory is correct one of the
biggest questions that I had when
leaving the film is did it actually
happen
we know that Sarah hallucinate it
appoints and was on medication
throughout the majority of it so a lot
of the film could all be in her head the
scar on her forehead displays that she
has had severe trauma which could have
led to her being out of touch with
reality when watching the talent show
Chris begins to sing to her directly in
an unnatural way about the hole and it
seems strange that no one else picks up
on this playing devil's advocate it
could in fact be Sarah who is the
villain here after all she took her son
and fled into the countryside
perhaps Chris's father was out there now
worried about where his son is as he
knows his wife is prone to fantasy and
that by being in her care he could be in
danger
Sarah never even confirms the abuse
style to her by Chris's father so this
may not have even happened the ending
shows that she's still paranoid and full
of anxiety willing to still distrust
Chris even though she's proven to
herself numerous times that he's human
when gazing into the hole it stares back
at her and does this instead reflect all
of the darkest part of herself the
phrase and if thou gets long into an
abyss the abyss will also gaze into the
comes from a book titled Beyond Good and
Evil that discusses how if one is faced
with the illusion of truth and is
fighting it sooner or later one will
actually find oneself complying with it
if one stares into nothingness long
enough eventually they will begin to
believe that something is there and from
this form their own opinions similar to
how Sarah did throughout the film in the
cave Sarah is grabbed by a creature that
transforms into her could this be a
symbol of her own inner turmoil that she
eventually overcomes emerges to escape
from due to confronting her inner demons
in the cave it's definitely my favorite
take on the film and showcases just how
complex of a character that sara is
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
and the ending of the hole in the ground
and if you took anything differently
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my
non-spoiler 3 minute review of the film
which would be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]